hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy where we talk education with a
variety of experts in the field
today i am excited to talk to my own
teammate dr adam green about new content
that we have just released on khan
academy for the start of the new school
year
before we get going i want to remind
folks that we
rely on donations from folks like you to
keep our work going
and you can find uh a spot to donate
right at the top of our khan academy
page or by going to khan academy.org
donate and we appreciate
as much or as little as you can give
so any any amount helps us continue to
do this work
i also want to recognize a few companies
that have really helped us during the
pandemic to make sure that we can
continue to support education and that
includes bank of america
at t google.org novartis fastly and
general motors
as i said today i am happy to welcome uh
adam green to talk about our
new content if you want to
catch up on anything you've missed uh
you can catch us on our podcast where we
are able to
you're able to catch an audio version of
our conversation later
so with that welcome adam
thanks kristen super happy to be here
and to talk about all the work the
content team's been doing over the last
year
so i can just jump right into it and
yeah get inside let's do it tell me tell
me what you've got new
awesome well i'll focus on uh on some of
the us content first specifically
science courses and new math courses
i'll start off by talking about science
super exciting there we have brand new
totally redesigned versions of several
courses including high school biology
high school physics ap physics one
addition in addition to that we've added
a lot more new content to our new ap
chemistry course and very excited about
a brand new course that we just launched
ap environmental science like i said i'm
excited about all of those things but i
want to talk about two of them in a
little bit more detail high school
biology and high school
or sorry high school biology and ap
environmental science
it's our high school biology course it's
important to know since we had a high
school biology course on khan academy
for the last couple of years this new
course is redesigned from the ground up
it's aligned with the next generation
science standards it contains two types
of practice exercise that are clearly
labeled for the first time ever on khan
academy we have exercises that are
called understand exercises and then we
have other practice exercises called
apply exercises
very exciting to be able to really
delineate those two
types of expectations that students and
teachers can have as they move through
the course i also want to talk about
that this this course actually both high
school biology and ap environmental
science showcase a fun new aspect of our
courses called lesson teasers these are
fun short little descriptions of the
lessons that you can see on the unit
pages for the course they're kind of the
khan academy equivalent of an easter egg
and when it comes to ap environmental
science this is our first ever ap
environmental science course even though
college board has offered that for more
than 20 years now
there was a really big redesign in 2020
and this course takes that into account
so our course was designed by a long
time ap environmental science teacher
incredibly skilled and also a long time
exam reader so she knows her stuff when
she was building this course
and uh and it's designed to to make sure
that students are prepared for that for
that exam
and to help with that it's clearly
aligned to the most up-to-date college
board ap environmental science standards
and like i said it also has those those
lesson teasers so also talk a little bit
about math courses we always have a lot
of new work happening in our math
courses so at this back to school so
just about a month ago in july we had
major additions to our high school and
aap statistics courses and in addition
to additions in our pre-calculus courses
arithmetic basic geometry and
pre-algebra as well as some brand new
get ready courses those have been
incredibly popular so we added new get
ready courses for statistics and for ap
statistics and ap calculus
i'm really excited about the high school
statistics course so i'll give like a
little extra blurb there
the course that course is now better
aligned to common core high school
statistics and probability standards and
there's new instructional and practice
content for standards in new and
interesting topics like study design
probability distributions and expected
value
and then when it comes to
the videos and exercises i'm happy to
announce that now they go beyond those
sort of rote procedures and context-free
data that sometimes can make statistics
less interesting so in this course now
learners kind of both apply concepts and
procedures in real world real-world
contexts can answer questions like
should you buy that extended warranty
that the sales person is trying to offer
you so
i'll i'll leave it at that um all
altogether there's just a ton of new
content very excited about it and the
content team has been working really
hard to provide this content for these
new courses for students all over the us
and eventually around the world
that's awesome and i know i have seen
you and the whole team hard at work for
a year creating these courses basically
so congratulations on all of their
launches
who do you think about when you're
designing these courses how do you think
about the audience for them and who
they're built for
yeah that's a good question and
historically khan academy really looks
at the independent learner
and we're still very focused and
want to make sure that everything we
produce is great for that just-in-time
learning for anybody out there who just
needs a little boost when it comes to
biology or precalculus or anything else
but these courses in particular we're
designing really with the classroom in
mind so really thinking about the
teachers and students in classroom
context and what can we do to help
support that learning
best as possible while still making sure
that these courses provide exceptional
value for anybody who's just coming in
to learn a concept inside or outside of
the classroom
so what does that look like then in
application for to be really also
thinking about teachers and what my
teachers
see or
be be
responding to in the new courses
yeah really i think that comes down to
standards alignment so i mentioned with
the science courses that these are built
with the next generation science
standards in mind all of our ap courses
are really built with the ap standards
directly in mind
they're built by and reviewed by
teachers in classrooms teaching these
subjects so all of those components
together we really hope that it's going
to supercharge what's going on in
classrooms
so how can people give us feedback on
whether these new courses are hitting
the mark or not
i'm really glad you asked that question
please everybody out there give us
feedback especially on these science
courses this is a the first time we're
designing these courses in this
particular way and you'll notice long
time khan academy users will notice that
these are a little bit shorter courses
than normal we did that on purpose
because we want feedback from teachers
and learners out there to tell us
what is it that that that this course
could add that would be really helpful
for your learning journey in the
sciences so you'll notice at the top of
each course
in the actual khan academy library
you'll see a call to action button that
says give feedback here click here for
feedback and you can click on that and
fill out a little form about any of our
new science courses and all of that
information comes right to me even right
now on my second screen here um i'm
looking at the the latest feedback that
we've gotten through this button you can
see right there at the bottom
read me a little feedback read me a
little feedback
here's from uh an ap environmental
science student uh who says the
questions and information is amazing i
just find the course a little short i
completed it and wish i would have
gotten more mastery points so yes i hear
you um they are a little short i'm so
excited that somebody has already gone
in and completed the entire ap
environmental science course so that's
great to hear
awesome i love hearing feedback about
how people people like our courses also
would love feedback about what would you
like to see so yes these are a little
bit on the on the short side
what would help you
have even a better experience in your in
your course let us know and we'll put
that on the list of things to add as we
continue to work on these courses and
release more and more updates in the in
the future months and year or so
i'm so impressed that someone's actually
gone through the whole course already
good for them
so as i've
poked into
some of the courses i know
um it was by style but there's some new
voices here tell me a little more about
them
yeah there are a lot of new voices in
our videos um so yeah we really had an
intentional effort especially in these
science videos to bring a more diverse
set of voices into our video creation
process and no no fear out there sal is
still making videos he's made videos in
our new science content but we've also
brought in more than a dozen new video
creators um this is mostly focused on
the high school and ap science so far
we're also hot in the middle of creating
middle school science for the first time
so that's a little sneak preview for
folks on ed talks that middle school
science content is coming soon and we'll
be using those same uh video new video
creators and even more new video
creators in our middle school content
but like i said sal is still in the mix
and is still creating great videos for
us
great well i know when i came on i was
fascinated by the process of how these
videos get made and how involved it is
can you share a little bit of that with
folks sure yeah it is a pretty long
process and we do that because we care
so much about the content we want to
make sure that we're providing the best
most accurate most engaging content
possible so uh when we're talking about
videos what really happens first is we
have our content experts that are
working with khan academy will write up
a request um for a new video and inside
that request it'll have things like the
standards that that video need to be
aligned to it'll have
any kind of misconceptions that we want
to make sure we address it'll have any
kind of language that we really make
want to make sure that students hear
and may include language that we want to
make sure that students don't hear quite
yet because the sequencing of the video
is such that we want to introduce uh
content and terms at certain times
during the course so it might not quite
be ready yet so we take that exercise
request we hand it over to a new video
creator they create a script that script
comes back to khan academy
content experts for review
there's back and forth with that
scripting process then the video creator
creates a first draft of a video which
then comes back again to the khan
academy experts and even i get into the
mix a little bit here and review that
video make notes send that information
back to the video content creator and
then they uh that process sort of
continues it usually takes two to three
drafts of the actual video after the
scripting process before we were really
aligned that this video was ready to be
published and that can take a couple of
weeks sometimes per video
wow
yeah i've seen this going back and forth
and all of the detailed comments and the
deep discussions about the content
itself and what's the right way to
present it so
um congratulations to you in the team
it's really a lot of work i know that's
gone into these
now when i put on my learning science
hat i know that it's not just the videos
but it's that active application and
exercises too so tell us a little bit
about the exercises and how you how you
create those
that's right yeah learning by doing
that's where you really you know where
the rubber hits the road uh so i've been
a teacher in the classroom too and and
watching videos is great for instruction
but really to solidify that
understanding you have to get into the
exercises like you said so if you
thought that the video process
was a little bit uh
lengthy and detailed the exercise
writing process is even more detailed
because we really really care about
accuracy scientific accuracy
but um also just making sure that the
content is aligned to standards and that
it's meeting students and teachers where
they need to be or we're meeting
expectations around the quality of what
happens in an exercise for for khan
academy so that process has around 15 or
16 steps per every practice exercise um
it starts off pretty much the same with
with one of those requests and then the
the editing and the reviewing just keeps
on going back and forth and then if
there's images or any uh math in the
question then that goes through a
separate review process and we just keep
on turning back and forth grinding on it
polishing it making it the best it can
possibly be before we release it to all
of our teachers and learners and then
again feedback there's feedback buttons
even within the exercises let alone
these feedback forms or going through
the forums to customer uh to our
support our community support staff and
the content team has an ear to the
ground anytime anything comes up
anything confusing anything
that anybody's concerned about
we take that feedback
and immediately see if we need to make
changes to those exercises or add
additional exercises remove things so
we're always looking for feedback and
always looking to make our courses even
better
great we had a question from youtube
from unkeep handy who says thanks for
the content i've checked all the new
courses great and so please add
exercises as well do all of our new
courses have exercises or are there some
to come or how can we uh
make sure we everyone's seeing all the
content that's available
thanks yeah all of our new courses that
i've been talking about do have
exercises but not all of the courses on
khan academy have exercises especially
some of our courses that have been up
there for a little while are very heavy
on the instructional side so videos in
some cases articles and not all of them
have exercises but that is our goal with
our small but mighty content team is to
eventually make sure that all of our
courses that we're showcasing here and
you can see a lot of the ones with the
little new buttons next to them those
are all the new things from last month
um all of those have exercises and most
of our other courses also have exercises
but occasionally you'll be able to pop
around and find one that's just videos
and articles and we hope that those also
will be useful but but like we were just
talking about really learning by doing
is important so we're hoping to to
eventually have exercises across across
all of our courses
great
just to let you know we're getting uh i
i'm seeing
compliments coming in so thank you for
squid nugget gnaw on youtube yajjaju on
facebook and uh rocio rosado on facebook
who have all said that they really like
the new courses and uh russia
specifically says thank you very much
for the ap chemistry much improvement so
glad to see folks are diving in already
and enjoying them
yes lauren our content creator for
chemistry will be very happy to hear
that thank you
yes she has worked hard on that
so we have lots of viewers outside the
us too what new content do we have
that's specific to countries outside the
us or languages other than english
sure yeah we have a lot of teams working
around the world uh some in some cases
creating their own content in their own
countries and in some cases
using the us content and localizing it
so translating it and making it
available for um for teachers and
students in other countries so i'll talk
a little bit about the first case of
some of the new content that's been made
in several countries uh for example
india there's tons of fresh new math and
science content for grade 12. and then
on the localization side there's new
localizations in india for hindi punjabi
and marathi coming next year uh hindi
and puja in punjabi is there right now
marathi will be coming next year
peru saw updates across math and some
science courses last month and it's
notable to say that this is the first
time that we're bringing science courses
to our peru site for khan academy so
very excited about that as a former
scientist especially and uh look to a
lot more content coming just in march of
next year to peru
in brazil we have new math and
portuguese language arts content in
addition to science new science courses
especially at the elementary and middle
school level there'll be new high school
science courses coming early next year
hopefully and also notable in brazil
that they're working on the new bncc
high school guidelines and creating math
and science courses aligned to those
guidelines
and finally i'll say that we i'm very
excited that we just launched our first
site in vietnam earlier this year and in
general for folks thinking about khan
academy just in the u.s context it is
global this khan academy experiment that
we have going and khan academy is used
in over 190 countries right now and
content is available in 50 languages
across across the globe um so very
excited to be able to talk about those
types of statistics
that is exciting
yeah and i have a question for for you
kristin so we're talking about all these
new courses and uh you know i have to
you know keep my content hat on here and
i'm curious what's most exciting to you
well
so i always have a soft spot for
statistics it's a course that i've
taught in the past
at different levels and
i kind of think that
we might be doing
better just as a global community if we
all had a little bit better
understanding of statistics
so i'm always excited i'm happy to see
we now have a high school statistics
course um so that's really exciting to
me but i'm also
really find it difficult to to pick one
course um
and
i know there's so much of the the work
that the team does that brings
really good learning science our
understanding of learning into the
courses so one of the things i like
across particularly these new science
videos is how much
the uh videos themselves indicate and
kind of
bring
wow
is it the world amazing isn't it amazing
how just things in science work how
sustainability and adaptability and the
the whole you know global
ecosystem works together and the videos
really manage to communicate that just
excitement about the world and i love
that and i think it's also really
important from a
motivation point of view to help keep
students excited about what they're
learning where things are
so i always appreciate that but let me
ask you what you like about the new
courses
wow yeah hard to follow that answer
that's that's so great um you know as i
mentioned before i'm a scientist by
training so i used to be a research
scientist so i have a very big soft spot
in my heart for anything science but
what's really getting me excited here is
these new science courses are definitely
exciting and i think are sort of
represent a shift in how we're
approaching science i think for the for
the better here
i love the breadth of our math content
and how that keeps on growing and keeps
on getting better and better
one thing that i'm looking forward to is
really as those those things start to
come together so as you mentioned like
in our statistics courses we have some
stimuli that talk about science it's in
our science courses we have a lot of
math in some of our environmental
science and obviously with ap physics
especially but even in chemistry and
some of our other courses we're really
getting into math so i like to look at
everything in a more holistic sort of
way and that there's not one particular
course that i love more than any other
course but really as a whole all of our
offerings together i hope come together
to serve our mission and and really give
a world-class education to anyone
anywhere um who can who can have access
to khan academy that's what that's what
keeps me and the rest of the content
team moving
great
we still have a little bit of time for a
little
more behind the curtain
peaks at these things so
i thought it might be fun to just talk a
little bit about
not surprisingly learning science and
how we fit those in so to
help folks who are out there understand
a little bit more about how these things
work adam and i over the past year
i have started a project to
start thinking about how we make sure
things like our hints and our rationales
are
aligned to what education research says
they should be and how we can write
hints in the best way to help students
really get the support they need to
answer questions
but can you just talk a little bit about
hints and rationales and why
those are important in in the exercises
that we create
sure yeah absolutely i could talk about
that for much longer than we actually
have time for so i'll try to keep it
short but uh overall the thing that i
really love about hints and rationales
these are things that come up when on
the right on the screen instant feedback
when a student answers a question if
they answer the question correctly they
can still see all of these rationales
and hints that come up or if they answer
a question incorrectly they can get a
hint that starts to stepwise work them
through each part of the question or a
rationale which is um
a different form of feedback that is uh
tagged exactly to each question answer
choice so usually if there's a question
that's more procedural where you need to
kind of work through step by step we'll
have a hint to help you work through
step by step but if the question isn't
that kind of procedural question it's
more conceptual or more applied then
we'll give more exact feedback at the
item answer choice level and that's
called a rationale but either way that
you get that feedback i think the most
important thing is that students can go
through questions at their own pace as
they get things correct and incorrect
they can see the the rationale for the
correct answer or the the hint so the
way to get the get the correct answer if
they're having trouble and then even
more powerfully they can just go through
the the exercise again they'll see
slightly different questions each time
they go through and then they'll get a
chance to apply that knowledge that
maybe they learned in a rationale or in
a hint to another shot and just to see
if they can solidify that concept in
their mind so i think between getting
that just in time
information about what's going on in
that question and then the opportunity
to have that growth mindset to persevere
and try again
make the the practice exercises on con
like very powerful
absolutely and so if you're a student
out there or if you're a teacher or a
parent coaching a student and you're
thinking should i ask for a hint or not
here's a little uh
tip to walk you through if you're
looking at the question and you think
i have no idea how to try to start to
answer this take a hint if you're
thinking
i might have an idea go ahead and try
that
go ahead and work through it on your own
it actually in the research shows that
if you're trying to
answer a question and you give it a try
that's
that's a good approach to take before
taking a hint and then if you don't get
it right go ahead and look at the hint
look at or the rationale depending on
what kind of question uh it is if it's
that procedural kind of question or not
but then keep asking yourself those
questions and then take a minute as adam
said to really think about that hint or
that rationale and maybe explain it to
yourself in your own words like
why you why oh yeah that's the next step
because i needed to
get the variables on one side or that's
oh that's that is the correct answer
because say it in your own words that
actually really will help you remember
it later so a little tip for those that
are out there learning and thinking
about um new questions and
uh
how to how to work through some of our
content and where things are
um
and i'll do a little a little shout out
here to some teacher tools because
teachers might be listening and the one
thing that i said earlier of you get
different questions every time you go
through incredibly powerful to be able
to have that that second chance also for
teachers though if you want to have all
of your students and answer exactly the
same questions so that you can go over
those in class and know exactly that
every student has seen each one of those
questions you have that option with our
teacher tools when you make an
assignment to all of your students you
can check a little box that says show
all of my students different questions
or show all my students the same
questions and that can be really useful
when you're doing a group discussion in
classrooms so that everybody has seen
the same things and you can go through
those hints and rationales as a group
as a different way to kind of get that
learning experience
great
we've got a question coming in from
facebook david clavercamp wants to know
how might khan academy be used for to
facilitate support of english language
learners in the future or teachers of
english as a second language
yeah um would you like me to take that
kristin
go for it go for it
please please chime in so
we we have our english language arts
courses up right now which is a little
bit different of a question than i think
you're asking
we're working on trying to figure out
the best ways to be able to support
english language learners on the site at
the moment we're trying to make sure
that at least
all the content that's been up for a
little while this is not true for the
the new science courses that just came
out quite yet but to make sure that all
of those are also available in spanish
to at least help english language
learners that are starting from a
spanish base so that you can see all of
our content both in spanish and in
english quite easily that's our goal
we're not quite there yet for some of
these new courses as i mentioned but
hopefully that'll that will help with
that with some of that transition along
with looking at our ela or english
language arts content hopefully at least
in the short term
will help learners like that we're also
very careful to make sure that our
reading levels for each of the grades is
matched to make sure that we're keeping
reading levels where they should be for
sixth graders 7th graders 9th graders
10th graders etcetera
so we're also hoping that that will
will help
folks that are learning english while
also
learning science and math on khan
academy
great thank you uh one more question uh
i'll i'll start and then you can follow
up mr new blocks on youtube any tips on
what to do if you get bored during class
uh this is obviously a question that we
get a lot from both students who are
looking for help and then teachers who
are looking to help students of how to
stay motivated and engaged in this
and so there's a couple of things that
i'll say that
i think are important so one is uh think
about
how might this apply to something that
you're interested in so
think about is there something i can
take away here that's gonna help me in a
hobby that i'm interested in is there
something that i can take away here
that's going to help me in a future job
that i might like
or is there something here that just is
really interesting about how the world
works and i can take and understand
better how something works how my
bicycle tires and the knee pedaling
helps move those tires there's a whole
bunch of interesting physics behind that
but think about like i said thinking
about how the things you're learning are
applying to the real world and are kind
of exciting one of the things that
salloy's talks about that's amazing is
we have so much collected knowledge
in
our textbooks or in the videos that
we've created and the exercises that
we're doing and what a privilege it is
for us to have all of this just readily
available think of all of the people
who've contributed to all of this
knowledge and where that is
can help kind of
think about how exciting it is to have
the opportunity to to work through some
of it
so that's some of the the big pieces all
right here's a really specific though
kind of more behavioral if you're
familiar with behavioral psychology is
have something where you can check in
every so often you might set it for five
minutes you might set it for 10 minutes
it just gives you a reminder and
whenever you see it you think am i
paying attention am i paying attention
is my mind wandered and that can
actually help train you to make sure
you're staying and attention and uh
being able to focus better and help
teach you that way so lots of different
things that that might help you stay
stay focused i have any thoughts for you
about staying and what happens if you
get bored in class
yeah and i've been there maybe not not
so long ago when they're boarding class
and i really like the idea of applying
like i'm thinking about what's going on
up on the board in the book on the video
in class or even on khan academy it can
relate to what's going on in in your
life and be more relevant
but the spin that i'll put on that is
sometimes it's for me it's really
interesting to think about connections
between courses so if i'm in a chemistry
course or like listening to a chemistry
lecture i'm a biologist at heart so i
love biology and i'm thinking about how
does this chemistry that i'm learning
relates to the biology that i love or
how does this statistic uh statistical
analysis that i find really interesting
how is that being applied could be
applied to a physics problem
even not a specific physics problem but
a general concept in physics how could
these two things relate and you can kind
of play those games in your mind a
little bit taking a subject or a topic
that you're interested in whether it's
an academic topic or something around
sports or
reading that you something that you've
read or some kind of hobby like kristin
mentioned and apply that to um to the
topic at hand and that definitely has
kept me interested in the past
great
so one more plug we would love to hear
from you about how you find these new
courses please give us feedback adam is
sitting ready to read it
[Laughter]
so please do uh take as you're going
through the courses let us know how you
find them and what else we can do to
make them better in particular
so thank you adam for joining us today a
reminder for folks that tomorrow we're
going to have uh sophie bossmany who is
works with our khan academy kids app
talk about content for uh kids who are
ages two through eight and what's new
there so looking forward to that thank
you all for joining today have a good
day
you